hello everyone I'm Alana oshara larsad
and welcome to my channel where today we
are talking about episode six of The
Last of Us on HBO I've been doing weekly
discussion podcasts the last one was
with Mike Flanagan and Kate see who make
sure you check that out about episode
five we may not have one for this
episode just because
um there's a video game conference
called the dice Awards happening this
week so a bunch of my guests are
traveling I'm traveling I'll try but I'm
not positive if we will be able to do it
but we still have time to do this little
one-on-one chat first things first I
think that episode six was a real treat
in terms of references
um definitely an episode that felt like
it was a delightful game fans
um I'm not sure how non-game fans will
have taken it but there were so many
Easter eggs in this episode not only the
two characters that we open up with but
also Jackson which is a pretty big
deviation from the first game but not so
much from the second of course this
directly leads into the second game and
life in Jackson was awesome that town
looked absolutely incredible and so
similar to it does in part two I was
born blown away again this show in terms
of set design is absolutely incredible
like one of the best that I've ever seen
and I'd be surprised if many people
disagree with me on that I think
we may have seen Dina I'm not sure
there's a very weird encounter where
Ellie's sitting at a table inside that
dancehall where they have that dance and
the argument in part two of the game of
course and somebody's staring at her and
she goes what and I'm pretty confident
that was Dina based on the ponytail but
no confirmation as of yet that I'm aware
of let me know if I missed something
this is however the first episode where
I have really felt like the game did a
better job of something so we start this
out with a three months passing and it
is finally winter and it is absolutely
beautiful some of the shots in this
episode I'm not sure who the Director of
Photography is but some of the just
individual shots of this episode were
absolutely stunning just beautiful
breathtaking work and while we do start
out with two characters walking their
relationship has developed at this point
Ellie is still pretty Brash and forward
and maybe doesn't have great social
skills in some cases she'll at least
responds a little bit more now there is
a back and forth we are clearly seeing a
Bond between the two of them but not too
much which is obviously a big theme of
this episode is that we don't want Joel
to open up to her too fast and he's
still very very guarded and defensive of
certain things like Sarah because that
is ultimately what leads to a conflict
in this episode we see Ellie once again
kind of learning about a life that she
is never going to have
well that she thinks she won't have and
I think as part of that we also see
probably one of the first vulnerable or
heartfelt moments from her as character
and I feel like the timing of this is
really well earned she says something
along the lines of like
everybody I've ever trusted or everyone
I've ever loved has left me it's either
died or left me and um that's really the
first time that she's admitted that
she's needed help and it happens a
couple of times in this episode I feel
like before now and again I always
expected the show to go in this
direction and it's nice to watch it pay
off
um but for now
she seemed very
unwilling to admit that she needed help
defensive forcefully independent even
though she's not independent at all and
she's finally at a point where she
admits that she needs him and I think
that's probably the biggest reason why
this episode took place
in the town rather than where the
conversations take place in the game
which is the damn which they just kind
of passed through because grounding
getting that home setting of family and
a community is really what the episode
is all about
and how two people become family
throughout the journey this is also at
the same time that we're seeing um some
sort of cracks in the relationship
between Joel and Tommy which was a sort
of side plot drama that I wasn't super
into it's not like I thought it was bad
I just wasn't that interested in it of
course there was a ton of tension seeing
Tommy for the first time oh my God the
dog coming up to Ellie all of that there
was a lot of tension in a lot of these
reveals that happened back to back in
this episode which I feel like was paced
very well seeing the two brothers hug
each other and then have a conversation
um but I feel like I wasn't quite as
into the Mellow drama about the life
that they left behind and who they were
and the things that they did I think the
performances were fantastic and you
fully believe that they have like this
set of pent up awkwardness as family
members who've been estranged for a
while maybe would have who've changed
and maybe lie on different sides of
political spectrums I think that they
nailed that in terms of performance even
in terms of the way it was shot that
stuff is very
expertly executed and I do think that
the
um melodrama as I'm calling it with
Tommy and Joel is necessary to actually
see Joel be willing to be vulnerable for
the first time this is the first time he
admits to being afraid or feeling
incapable of anything and he kind of
needed Tommy to be there to be able to
do that and I felt like that was a very
powerful choice of like he's got this
really Brave face on for everybody else
especially Ellie of course and it's got
to be a huge relief to him
to not have to do that around Tommy
which of course he doesn't so I love
that choice as well and I felt like that
made sense but yeah I do love the final
vulnerability of the hot to hot scene um
between Tommy and Joe like that was just
just beautiful and of course also leads
very quickly into the next one which is
that Hot Tot um dramatic scene with
alien Joel which is very similar to the
game but I actually think in this case
the game did a better joke I feel like
in the game where you realize that Joel
is going to show up and and he's going
to take her just tugged at my
heartstrings a lot more I think maybe it
was because there was so much drama in
this episode and a lot of tension
a lot of interpersonal conflict that
that one conflict didn't feel like the
Highlight that it maybe should have felt
like it was to me I think maybe it felt
a little bit rushed
um and so that's kind of why I feel like
maybe I could have done without some of
the other conflicts is like I would have
loved for them to focus really more on
that decision of of Joel
thinking that he was going to leave
Ellie and that was going to be the end
of it and I would have really liked that
to have sat with us for longer than it
did because I think it it felt like it
was like 10 minutes it felt really fast
and thus I never believed it felt like a
decision that came out of Norway that we
didn't have a lot of context for yeah it
just uh it just didn't hit as hard I
think the episode was just a little bit
a little bit too rushed um or similar to
the previous episode the previous two
episodes actually with the Kathleen
stuff it's like I would have liked a lot
more of certain things or a little bit
less of them
um rather than just like sprinkles of a
couple of bits of drama that we only
like sort of glimpsed the sight of I
think in general I felt like these last
three were not as strong as the first
three but I think that that's really
just because the first three episodes
are so unbelievably good hard act to
follow no matter what and I know a lot
of uh TV shows have trouble in the
middle um that doesn't make me any less
excited for the next two episodes but
yeah even the university part
um it was nice to again see some cool
Easter eggs and see how that played out
and and especially expecting what was
going to happen at the end there and the
final shift where Ellie is going to need
to look after Joel what I didn't like so
much here was the University you know
they get there after what should have
been I think a bigger emotional struggle
then get to the university and the
fireflies aren't there this is the path
that we're heading towards the whole
time and there was very little sign of
Devastation it was more of a like oh on
to the next one where I felt like in the
game at that point
um or really in general it should have
been like oh [__] they're not here we've
been waiting for months like it just
felt like it should have been a more
impactful realization a more devastating
realization rather than just keep moving
it was just played off very casually
that they had left the university I felt
where there should have been a little
bit more depth there and again maybe I'm
only feeling that way because I'm
comparing it to the game which I feel
like definitely like that depth gripped
me very strongly but it was ultimately
very fast they don't spend much time in
the university and then Joel of course
gets stabbed quite quickly to the extent
that we didn't even really have too much
um insight into the Cure here which kind
of would have been
the right place to put it I would have
thought like I feel like this is the
area where we let the audience know what
the fireflies are trying to do and if
it's working or if it's not working or
how they progressed on a cure and what
this means for the world but I'm
assuming that that's not there because
it's going to show up somewhere else in
the show it just seemed like it would
have been a really nice neat place to
put that context or that drama
they clearly aren't here they left why
did they leave what went wrong why
didn't the tests work if they didn't
work and what does it mean for Joel and
Ellie's Journey but yeah we didn't
really get a ton of that um I feel like
the University was more there to look
cool and it did and then
have the action sequence there at the
very end with Joel and I will say
the end of this almost made me go wait
did he die because video game wise it
makes sense that you go off and get
someone and come back and you Med kit
him up or whatever it was it seemed uh
like that dude really seemed like he was
dead
like surely you don't kill Joel here
there's no way that's what's happening
but it made me question it which is like
a great way to end the episode I think
and I also felt like watching Bella
Ramsay uh of a of a Joel um
was her best performance yet I thought
that that was absolutely wonderful such
sincere desperate Devastation as a
result of seeing him get injured again
when she's just admitting how much she
needs him finally and having that
vulnerability so that this episode did a
lot of groundwork in terms of like
actually feeding us people's
insecurities and explaining behaviors
and giving us more insight into what's
going on in their heads as they're
trying to brave this journey for one
another and I feel like it did a
fantastic job of of exactly doing that
thing that it needed to do some of the
best performances of the entire series
hands down I think it was it was just
sort of a bit of a pacing problem again
the drama in this episode felt like felt
like melodrama because it was so fast it
was just so so so quick some of the
scenes that I would have liked to have
had more impact here where they did have
a lot more impact in the game also felt
very very quick and while we did get
more detail on certain things like I
love learning about Jackson and how the
town operates and seeing that commune um
I felt like that was a fantastic choice
and getting more detail there and the
movie theater and all of that there were
details that were expanded on that I
really liked but the emotional Stakes
were just so fast that it's almost like
we try to grab one of them and then just
stick just um flooded away but they did
get the the important things down they
did get Joel and Ellie's relationship to
a point where I feel like it needed to
be at this point and they've they've
paced that very very very well stringing
us along slowly watching these two
people get closer and closer and closer
and
thought the the Sarah reveal was really
strong too what Ellie finds out about
Sarah
and um obviously Joel is still very
defensive about that oh also the Joel
panic attack stuff that was new and uh I
feel like really gave his character a
bit more life yeah I think I ultimately
left this episode like very happy with
Joel and Ellie's characters and that
character arcs and the journey those
characters are going on just felt like
some of the scenes were
a little either too fast so they felt
sort of unnecessary and melodramatic or
perhaps they were just a few too many
conflicts
um so those two characters in their
conflict couldn't be fleshed out in the
way but I would have loved all of that
said
um I know a lot of people out there
think that this is the perfect show and
so uh inevitably going to be mad at me
for not lobbing this one I would still
have given it like an eight like it's
still very good I think it's just you
know in the middle things are tough it's
really hard to do and um
I feel like that the way this is gonna
break up is the way a lot of shows are
which is one two and three fantastic
four five and six a little less good but
still very good just because the
pacing's so hard but they have achieved
exactly what they needed to which is the
more important thing and then I'm
expecting the last three to also be
bunched together a bit like a movie and
be fantastic as well you don't think
I've forgotten anything I think that's
it
um I'm still streaming the game when
possible again traveling this week so
it's a little bit tough but trying to
stream it mostly alongside the show and
uh will maybe have the podcast up this
week where I talk to a couple of friends
about it I'm not sure I'll do my best
but if not I will see you next week to
talk about more Last of Us thanks for
watching everyone bye